STEPHANIE WONG: This
week, we're talking
about data storage, Anthos, and
eagerly anticipating next year.
I'm Stephanie Wong.
And welcome to the
last 2019 episode
of "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the lowest latency
news
There's a ton of data out
there, and the more you have,
the harder it can be to move.
Google Cloud's Storage
Transfer Service
can help you move terabytes
of data from anywhere
to the Cloud.
And now in beta, you can even
move your data from on-prem
with the same set of tools.
Two of the biggest
announcements this year
were Anthos and Cloud Run.
But these two work
even better together.
There's a whole bunch
of new features,
like traffic
management and on-prem
support that come with Anthos.
And you can even try it for
free until May next year.
Cloud Run is the easiest
way to run containers.
But what if your app
isn't containerized?
It's time to
modernize with Migrate
for Anthos, which can
help you transform
your virtual machines
into containers,
no matter where they're hosted.
Check out the guides, and
try these out for yourself.
2019 has been a busy year.
We've seen all kinds of
exciting announcements,
like the new features being
added to Kubernetes and Anthos
or around the exciting
AI and ML updates that
make it even easier for you
to create your own models.
The busiest time this
year was all around
Google Cloud Next with
different talks, demos,
and lots of great showcases.
And I'm sure next year,
it will be even busier.
On behalf of the
team here, thank you
for checking out
"This Week in Cloud"
to stay up to date
with the latest.
2020 has so much more
to come, so stay tuned.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in
the Cloud next year.